THE SENATE TERM. BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE- ORDER AND
WILL. GO THROUGH SOME
DEPARTMENT ISSUES RELATED TO.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION SO WILL START
WITH THE FIRST ISSUE. THIS
ISSUE NUMBER ONE ROLL CALL.
CENTER SKINNER MORLOCK CENTER
ABOUT. OKAY WILL HAVE ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WE HAVE THE SPEAKERS
COME FOR PLEASE. THREE I
BELIEVE. ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS
READING REAL BILL TATUM
COMMUNITIES FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE UNDER AGED TWENTY SIX
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT ORDER YOU
PLAN ON. PROCEEDING WITH. I
ASSUME YOU FIGURED OUT WHO'S
GOING TO SPEAK FIRST ALTHOUGH
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR. I HAVE THE
MICROPHONE NOT YES. GOOD
MORNING. RIGHT RECTOR THE
DIVISION OF A DAHLE INSTITUTION
CCR I'M TODAY TO SPEAK TO YOU
ABOUT A REQUEST FOR YOU UNDER
READ UNITY THIS REPORT INCLUDES
NOT POINT FIVE CHINS IN SIX
POINT TWO MILLION IN GENERAL
AND FOR BUDGET YOU'RE TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY FIVE AND TEN
POINT ONE MILLION AND FIND.
NEED TO. THIS IS. FOCUSED YOUTH
OFFENDER REHABILITATIVE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR AND THIS
PROVIDE THE RE. IS TARGET
UNIQUE NEEDS AFTER. YOU THE BY
PENAL CODE ARE INDIVIDUAL
COMMITTED TO SEE YOUR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF A- YOU THE-
CONSISTENT HAVE THE- RATE EVER
SO. IN OUR SAYS AT
APPROXIMATELY ONE. AND THEY ALL
EXPERIENCE THE HIGH RATE THE
INTEREST ORDERS IS. FIFTY ONE
PER ROLE WITHIN JUST HEAR. IT
IS NATIONALLY. ACROSS MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH FIELDS THANK
YOU FOR THOSE UNDER AGE TWENTY
FOUR. ARE STILL UNDER SICK RAIN
DEVELOP. FURTHER IT IS NASH
RECOGNIZED WITH MENTAL HEALTH
X. THANK YOU THE FENDER
INCREASE SELF FROM. I
EXPERIENCING TERM EVENT. IN
THEIR YOUTH AND FURTHER EXHAUST
BY IN CAR. THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES A COMPREHENSIVE CLEAR
AND CONCISE. SOLUTION FOR OUR
YOUTH OFFENDERS BY TREATING
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS WITH THREE
OR FOUR KEY COMPONENTS. FIRST
IT MOVES ARE YOU OFFENDER
PROGRAM TO A MANDATORY PROGRAM.
THIS ENSURES OUR YOUTH
OFFENDERS ARE NOT INFLUENCED BY
THEIR NEGATIVE PEERS UPON ENTRY
ARE RATHER INFLUENCED BY THEIR-
THIS IS CRITICAL AS THESE YOU
ANDERS INTO THE SYSTEM WITH
OFTEN NEGATIVE OUTLOOK.
EXPERIENCE GAINES INSTRUMENT
MINDSET TEND TO NATURALLY
GRAVITATE TO THEIR NEGATIVE
TEARS AS A CONSEQUENCE. THESE
NEGATIVE INFLUENCES IN OUR
SYSTEM DISCOURAGE PROGRAMMING
FOR THESE YOUTH OFFENDERS BY
ESTABLISHING A MANDATE TO THIS
PROGRAM IT BECOMES RECOGNIZED
BY THE INMATE POPULATION
OVERALL AT ALL YOUTH OFFENDERS
UPON THE ARE REQUIRED TO GO TO
THIS PROGRAM. THEN IMMEDIATELY
CONNECTED WITH POSITIVE MENTORS
AS THEIR PEERS TO HELP ENSURE
THEY CAN BEST RELATE WITHOUT
OFFENDER. CURRENTLY 44% OF OUR
YOUTH OFFENDER POPULATION IS
NOT PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM AS THE VOLUNTARY
STANDARDS. SECOND IT PROVIDES
FOCUSED YOUTH OFFENDER
REHABILITATIVE SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITIES FOR THESE OFFENDER.
WITH TRAINED- FULLY SELECTED IN
MAINE MENTORS THESE COMMUNITIES
ARE COMPRISED OF FOUR SUPER
INSTEAD FIVE HUNDRED OR MORE.
IS INSTITUTIONS HOUSE.
LOCATIONS BEEN SO TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE WHITE OF R. G.
AND NATURE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WILL TO GET VISITS FROM
THEIR FAMILIES. IT ALSO ENSURES
LOCATIONS THAT BEST MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR POPULATION
IN TERMS OF DORM HOUSING VERSUS
SELF HOUSING. ONE PARTICULAR
LOCATION PLEASE THE PERSON WILL
SERVE AS THE MODEL FOR OUR
YOUTH OFFENDER PROGRAM. THIS IS
DUE TO THE LOCATION SUCCESSFUL
HISTORY AND CULTURE OF OVERALL
POSITIVE PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
PEER MENTORING LOW LEVEL OF
INCIDENTS AND A LEVEL. A
DORMITORY STYLE AND- THESE
COMMUNITIES WILL PROVIDE
TARGETED TRAINING FOR STAFF.
AND OFFER UNIQUE PROGRAM
SPECIFIC TO THE NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH OFFENDER THIS INCLUDES
CONTRACTING FOR A AN EVIDENCE
BASED TEN WEEK TRAUMA FOCUSED.
I AM WHICH PROVIDES ON EIGHTEEN
SAFETY FROM TRONG. TREATING P.
AND ALSO ABUSE. THESE
COMMUNITIES ALSO PROVIDE ROBUST
PROGRAMMING OPPORTUNITIES TO
THE YOU INCLUDING JOB SKILLS
ACADEMIC. EIGHT EIGHT AB
EXCELLING COLLEGE COURSES
TECHNOLOGY AND ACCESS TO
LOCATION. FORCE IS FOURTH THIS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES STAFFING AND
TRAINING A SENSE PER SIX ASKED
THEIR STAFF. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT THAT WE'RE INSURING
THAT WE ARE TRAINING OUR STAFF
ON HOW BEST TO ENGAGE WITH
THESE OFFENDERS AND HOW BEST TO
ASSIST THEM EITHER A POSITIVE
TRANSFER ME. AS WELL AS
INSURING MONITORING ON
SUSTAINABILITY THE PROGRAM.
OVERALL THIS PROVIDES ARE SOLID
PLATFORM ON THE BEST WAY TO
TREAT ARE YOUTH BENDERS. IT
ENSURES THAT DURING TWELVE
MONTHS THEIR OWN PERSONAL.
ARMORS IN A POT PRO AND LEADING
TO THEIR OWN PERSONAL CHOICE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT
TRANSFORMATION. AND AFTER THE
INITIAL YEAR OFFENDERS CONTINUE
TO PARTICIPATE IN SUCH PROGRAMS
OFFERED STATEWIDE. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO INTRODUCE TODAY. ARE TO
STAFF HERE FROM VALLEY STATE
pTHE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THEIR OWN YOUTH UNDER BROWN.
ELIZABETH ALPHA CORRECTION
CANCER TO SUPER. AND CORRECTION
OFFICER BOBBY. EACH WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF STATEMENT
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. OKAY THANK
YOU YOU CAN PROCEED. AND THE OF
THE SENATE. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE ON THIS PLATFORM
I'D LIKE TO- LET YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR PROGRAM
VALLEY STATE PRISON WHICH ARE
DISTRAUGHT TURNING IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX IN AND TO GET
PROGRAM THANK. AT THE IT WOULD
CHANGE THE MENTORS AND SLY THE
AND. THESE WERE THE EIGHT
EIGHTEEN UNDER THE AGES OF
TWENTY. THESE YOUTH AND ON IT
MONTH PROGRAM AND THAT'S FOLLOW
WITH. THAT JUNIOR MENTORING
FOR. TO IF THEY CAN APPLY FOR
AND THEN THEY BE INTERCEPTS
WELL CURRENTLY WE HAVE TO
HUNDRED YOU TO ENTER PROGRAM.
WE HAVE A MEN TO BE MENTORS ALL
THE PROPER AND- AS SOON AS A
THE YARD WITHIN TWO. THEY'RE
NETWORK. IN STAFFER ON BOARD.
WE OPENED DIAL WITH THEM SIT
THERE AND WE CAN WITH GUYS AND
MEANT. TO MAKE IT A POSITIVE
CHANGING THE CULTURE. FOR ALL
OF TO BE IN THE A PRESS
ENVIRONMENT SO THEY CAN FOR
IT'S- SO THAT'S WHY WE'VE DONE
WITH. THE MAN. I EXPENSES BACK.
A LOTTHEM WERE GANG MEMBERS
HAVE TO BE NOW THAT ARE ON
THEIR ROAD TO RECOVERY AND THEY
HAVE A POSIT INFLUENCE AS WELL
WHICH WOULD BE AS TO THE
PERFECT FOR SIX IS POSITIVE
THAT. ROLE MODELS AND A TWELVE
PROBE. FOLLOW AT WE ALSO HAVE
EVENT. IN ME THE TWENTY BANDS
FOR THE U. OFFENDER AS YOU KNOW.
CONNECTS WITH THE DEFENDERS
DAILY- WE HAVE MONTHLY MEETINGS
WITH A MENTOR. AND SO WE GET
THEM ALL INVOLVED THEY SUBMIT-
TESTIMONY TO IT WE GET IF YOU
SEE IF YOU WILL FAN MAIL FROM
OTHER INMATES FROM OTHER
PRISONS WANTING TO COME TO
VALLEY STATE PRISON OR UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER BY STATE
PRISON AND I'VE BEEN A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER FOR THE
PAST TWENTY THREE YEARS. I'VE
WORKED AT THREE DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS. AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF. IF THINGS HAPPEN WITHIN
PRISON WALLS. NOW WHEN I CAME
ABOUT THE STATE PRISON I
ENTERED A DIFFERENT ATMOSPHERE
I BEGAN OUR GOODNESS ALTHOUGH
IN A WARRANT MR FISHER. ON THE
WEALTHY PROGRAM. IN JUST
JUDGING BY THE BY THE FACT THAT
I'VE I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE AROUND ARE YOU FULL OF. IN
MAY. BOTH HEREBY SUPER OF
PASSENGERS TO. AND BY THE
FATHER RAISING CHILDREN WE HAD
THE IDEA OF WHAT THAT THAT WE
BEGAN AND WE'RE VERY CALM THAT
I WOULD AND IT HAS WORKED. WE
FIRST BEGAN ARE ARE. DIFFERENT
IN OTHER SUMMER OF TWENTY. AND
WE WERE BE ABLE TO GET WE WERE
ABLE TO THIS OFF THE ACT SEVEN
JANUARY YES I AM THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND. AND I HELP AND THIS
IS WITH THE- I AM THE MENTORS
THAT WE GET. OUR MENTOR IT WELL
IN OUR OUR PRO WE HAVE A STRONG.
CELL BOB. MULTI TIERED. OF
PROGRAM UP OF FACILITATOR.
LEADING YOUR MENTOR MEN IN THE
BUILDING AND THEY'LL HAVE THIS
CALM GOAL OF ME. AND SERVICING
APPROACH AT EVERY IN ORDER TO
BETTER SERVE. EACH IN THE YOU
THE FOR. OUR MENTAL UP
INVOLUNTARY. MENTORS WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THEIR MENTEES.
HELPING THEM ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS AND HELPING HIM THEIR
GOALS. WE REQUIRE THAT ARE
MEANT. I RECEIVED TRAINING WE
DO DO THAT. THE NET THAT'S A
WITH A FULL OUR ADULT BRAIN
VIDEO SOME OF MY A MENTOR
TRAINING MANUAL THAT A POWER
POINT AND VIDEO COMING UP. AND
I NOTICED THAT WITH THIS TIME
THANK THE MENTOR THAT WE DO
HIGHER THERE THERE IS THIS NEW
FAQ THAT I'VE KNOWN AND I'LL TO
CALL THAT TO A RE. BUT THE
MENTORS THAT WERE HIRE A COME
ON AND THERE ARE. SOMEWHERE
ALONG LINES OF A REBUILT THEM
FOR THEMSELVES WHEN THEY ARE
PAIRED UP WITH ME. ARE WITH ME
HE'S BEEN BEGIN CARE THAT YOU
TAKE ON YOUR RESPONSE. I AM
THEN THERE'S A GROUP ABOUT THAT
ROAD. AND WITHIN THAT BOND THAT
THEIR DE. IT GROWS. ALL THE WAY
MANY AND MEANT AS A WEEK WE'VE
GRAY A COMMUNITY OUT OF THAT AT
ABOUT STATE PRISON. SO WITH
THIS AND THE INMATES THERE'S A
LOT OF A INCREASE CAN. UP THERE
THE INMATES UNDERSTAND THAT NOT
THEY DON'T TO A NOW ASK
QUESTIONS THERE THEIR THERE
WILL READILY ATTACK TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF STAFF WILLING TO
AN QUESTION AND HELP THEM.
THEY'LL CALL FROM TIME TO TIME
AND CAN ABOUT A USEFUL FOR. IN
THE YOU KNOW I'M TALKING ABOUT.
A LINE STUFF THAT WE HAVE. I'M
IN A IN A BUT I JUST I BELIEVE
THE THIS IS AN EARLY. FOR STAFF
OUR INSTITUTE. I THAT WOULD BE
UNDER THAT WE'RE NOT. CULTURAL
CHANGE IN THE BELIEF SYSTEMS
THAT BENEFIT LONG TERM SAFETY
TO OUR COMMUNITY. M. WHAT MISS
ALICE SAID ABOUT THE ONE YEAR
PROGRAM IT'S BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT WE DO THIS- I ALWAYS
THINK OF THE ONE YOU PROGRAM
LIKE A CLOCK AS IT I'LL G.
BLOCK. IN OUR OFFENDER HE
CAUGHT TWELVE O'CLOCK IN FROM
TWELVE TO. SOMETIMES THEY MIGHT
BE RESISTIVE. SOMETIMES IT
MIGHT BE NOT TRUSTING GONE
THROUGH TRAUMA RECENTLY
OBVIOUSLY THEY JUST GOT THEIR-
UP FROM THREE TO THREE TO FOUR
A FULLY ARE IN INVOLVED IN OUR-
OUR PRO. AVERY TAKEN SOME
CLASSES THERE ON A DAY TO DAY
MEETING WITH THEIR MENTORS AND
RECEIVE BONUS CHECKS AT SIX
FIVE AND SIX YOU MAY RECEIVE
SOME SORT OF A RIDEABLE
DISCIPLINARY- YOU KNOW ISSUE
WITH THEM. EVEN IN USUALLY BY
SEVEN. THEY'RE BUYING IN THEIR
LEARNING THEIR UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WE'RE DOING. OF BY OUR
CURRICULUM THAT WE TEACH IN THE
SUPPORT THEY GET AND THEY ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE- OUR MENTORS
IMMENSE. STAND WHEN THEY WHEN
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM. THEY CAN
COME TO US THEY CAN COME TO ANY
STAFF AND THEY HAVE THE SAME
THAT THEY TELL US. THEY TELL US
YOU KNOW WHAT WE TRUST YOUR
PROGRAM BECAUSE WE KNOW. YOU'RE
NOT GONNA THROWS AWAY THAT'S
WHAT THEY TELL US. SO WITHOUT.
BY ELEVEN INCH. THERE CAN
ACROSS. OUR PROGRAM AND WE'RE
SHAKE. YOU IS A COMING. MARS LA
WE DID NOT RAISE. HOW I REQUEST
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU. MEASURE
HOW WILL YOU MEASURE THE
PERFORMANCE OF THIS AND- DO YOU
HAVE SOME METRICS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO USE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT PROGRAMS GOING
TO BE SUCCESS. WE DO. SURE WE
DO HAVE IN THIS PROPOSAL
REQUEST FOR THOSE RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH THE
RESEARCH BRANCH IN A CONTRACT
ESTABLISH METRICS- I'M USING
VALLEY- MODEL THAT WERE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE SAYS RAM A MEASURE.
GOING TO BE PART OF BUDGET. SHE
SAID YES THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THIS PROPOSED. THE GIVEN
PROGRAMS A DRUG TRANSFERRED TO
DEPARTMENT HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES THE AGES TWENTY FIVE
AND THIS GOES TO TWENTY FIVE
HELLO. THE DIFFERENCE CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA ABOUT THE
OVERLAP. IN THOSE PROGRAMS THEY
ARE TO A SEPARATE AND DISTINCT
PROGRAMS THESE ARE THOSE ARE
SENTENCED TO CDC ARGENTIA DAHLE
INSTITUTIONS. AND WE PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THOSE THAT ARE IN
THAT YOUTHFUL OFFENDER PROGRAM
PAGE TWENTY. WELL THE ONE.
GOING UP TO TWENTY FIVE THE
JUNO PROGRAM ISN'T A TRUE
THOUGH SOME OF THEM. OBVIOUSLY
BETTER THAN DOLE ARE STILL
GOING TO THE DOOR PROGRAM TO
GET PUT INTO THE- JUVENILE
PROGRAM. YES THERE ARE SOME AT
THAT AGE BETTER JUVENILE
PROGRAM THIS PROPOSALS FOCUSED
ON THOSE THAT ARE IN THE ADULT
SYSTEM WITHOUT. YEAH OKAY WE
HAVE THAT ARE LIKE TO MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE- OVERLAP
IN. WHAT A DISTINCTIVE ARE I'VE
BEEN TO VALLEY PRISON SO I. NO
THE FACILITY IT'S SO ARE YOU
GOING TO REQUIRE ANY
MODIFICATIONS TO THE FACILITY
TO ACCOMMODATE YOUR- IT'S GOING
TO BE ANY CHANGES TO THIS THE-
PHYSICAL. STRUCTURES SERVE
BATHROOMS OR ANY OTHER KINDS OF
THE RESIDENTIAL PART OF IT.
PART OF THIS PLAN THAT YOU HAVE
I THINK VALLEY SET UP TO. IT'S
ANY SECRET WITH- A CLASSROOM
SETTING TO USE THE PROGRAM
CURRENTLY RUNNING RIGHT NOW IN
MODULES YEAH- BUT DUE TO THE
INCREASE WE'RE GONNA GET WE DO.
ASK ROOMS AVAILABLE. FOR THEM.
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THAT YOU
HAD LIKE THE JOB TRAINING.
OPPONENTS ON THIS DESCRIBE.
YOUR EDUCATION JOB TRAINING
COMPONENTS FOR THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WILL BE GOING THROUGH YOUR
PROGRAM. WORKER YOU-
ANTICIPATING IT DOES INCLUDE.
DESTRUCTION LABOR OF
FRIENDSHIPS SO. HE HIGH SCHOOL
COLLEGE WHAT WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
THE BROTHER THE PROGRAM FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE YES SIR CURRENTLY
WE DO HAVE ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED AND
INCLUDING THINGS SUCH AS
BIOLOGY WE HAVE. IN WE'VE GOT
YOU L. WHICH IS LIKE A
CONSTRUCTION. TRAINED IN A
MULTITUDE OF LOCATIONS IN
EDUCATION WE OFFER COLLEGE
THEY'RE ABLE TO GO TO A TENER
GREASE WE ALSO OFFER JUST A LOT
OF LIFE SKILLS AND TOOLS
THROUGH ARE CORRECT IN THAT
CELL. THERE ARE ONLY STATE
PRISON WE HAVE OVER A HUNDRED
SELF HELP GROUPS AS WELL. NOT
ONLY ARE THEY AN- INVOCATION ON
EDUCATION BUT SELF HELP GROUPS
BUT THEY CAN SIGN UP
INVOLUNTARY. HAVE A USEFUL FOR
IMPORTS AND WE HAVE A- THAT'S
FOR THE DEFENDERS WE DO IS WE
SAY THE STOCKS FROM THE UNITY
THEY COME IN A LIVE WITH THE
INMATE OR FOR PLANTS ANDERSON
MENTORS. ASK WHICH I REALLY
ENJOY THE SAY. BOB I TEACH DE
UM MENTORS HOW TO TRAIN A DOG
IN THE TEACHING LIFE SKILLS. SO
THESE DOGS ARE RESCUED AND
THEIR ADOPTED BY THE COMMUNITY
BY SEEING THOSE AND SEVERAL
OTHER PRISONS FELT THAT YEAH SO
OURS. AND THEY GO TO. ASSIST
WITH FOR THE YOUTH CENTER ABOUT.
ONE OF THE GUYS IN VISITED
PRISON WITH MAY IS REALLY INTO
THAT. YEAH DANNY TREJO. ALL
YEAH IN THE DARK THE DOG THIRTY
IN THE SENSE OF. YOU KNOW THE.
FOR HE'S A GOOD GUY NO IS OF
COURSE MY ACTUALLY IS A FRIEND
OF. YOU KNOW WHAT TO IT NOW IS
A GOOD GUY I. TALKED TO ABOUT
THE HE- THE- JUST. A FIFTY WITH
US AND- THE OF THE MANY
FACILITIES I VISITED. HE
MENTIONED THAT THE DOG THERE IS
A REAL GOOD THING AND YOU KNOW
SO IT WORKS WITH PEOPLE ON.
HAVING THAT THAT. CONTRACT.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GET THE STAFF
WHEN YOU'RE PICKING WHO'S GONNA
BE WORKING HER YOU TWO OF OUR
BELIEF THAT THE EXPERIENCE OF
WORKING WITH YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
THE THEN YOU'RE GONNA YOU TO
WHEN YOU. THIS WHO'S GONNA BE
WORKING IN THE PROGRAMS. THAT
HAVE SOME SPECIAL EXPERIENCE OR
QUALIFICATIONS TO WORK WITH
YOUNGER INMATES SECOND A PART
OF THEIR OF THE PRINTER FOR
SELECTION OF THE STAFF. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO STOP
THEIR IN THIS PROGRAM OF BOTTOM
AND THEN A ARE AGREEABLE TO
SUPPORTING WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
THAT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR FOR OUR TRAINING AND
THEM AND BRING IN EXPECT. FROM
I DON'T. REVISED VERSIONS
COUNTY TEN I WENT THROUGH A
RATHER DRAMATIC. THANK SO WE
REALLY STARTED ON DOWN HOW WE
MIND THEN GO THE RIVER WAS A
COP. BUT WHAT WHAT WE DID IS WE
CHANGED MANY OF OUR YOU.
EVERYTHING WE ESTABLISHED. ALL
RESULTS ORIENTED GOVERNMENT
ARMED JIHAD ALL THAT IT WAS
EVERY WE OPERATE WITH BUSINESS
PLANS AND I'M NOT SAYING YOU
HAVE TO DO THIS BUT I JUST. ALL
I GET IS. HOW MANY FISH DO WHAT
WHAT COST AND I'M NOT BACK TO
APPRECIATE PRESENTATION BUT BUT
YOUR YOUR BUSINESS PLAN AND
TWENTY SIX SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
WHAT IS SAID WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS MENTORSHIP PROGRAM AND-
THIS MANY. THIS PAGE AND
RESULTS WERE LOOKING FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN YOU'D SAY THIS IS WHAT
WE WANTED TO DO AND THIS IS
WHAT THE ACTUAL. AND THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE GONNA. TWENTY
NINETEEN AND YOU DO IT AGAIN.
THE NEXT YEAR IS GOING TO HAVE
A CRACK. WHAT WE WOULD DO IT
WHAT YOUR GOAL WAS AND HOW YOU
MET YOUR GOAL THAT WE CAN TRUST
BY WHAT WE'RE SPENDING AND
WHETHER. WELL I'M- AB VALLEY
STATE DID YOU HAVE ANY KIND OF
WRITTEN ANALYSIS THAT HERE'S
WHAT WE- THIS YEAR'S WAS OUR
VISION. AND A YEAR LATER HEY
HOW DO WE NEED THAT IN DID WE
MEET THE GOALS RIVER BETTING
ARE YOU STILL DOING. CURRENTLY
OUT WE ARE STILL DOING THAT OF
COURSE IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
A NEVER ENDING THING- HOWEVER
UP TO THIS POINT OUR RETENTION
SUCCESS RATE IS 92% WELL HOW DO
YOU MEASURE THAT. TO WIN THESE
GERMAN COME INTO THE PROPOSED
TO THE PROGRAM. IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE PROGRAM
ACCORDING TO OUR STANDARDS. YOU
HOLD EVERYONE TO OUR STANDARD.
AND IF AND ACCOUNTABLE. FOR IN
THE- AND MAKE IT VERY AND THE
CLEAN. UP INCLUDING ATTENDANCE
AND EVERY EVERYTHING THAT COMES
ALONG WITH THAT AND ARE ABLE TO
GRADUATE THAT'S THAT'S WHERE WE
AND THAT'S FOR THEIR- WE
CONSIDER THE END OF. THAT FIRST
YEAR ONLY ABOUT RESERVE IS.
THIS IS THE WE WILL HAVE A OF.
THE ONE THAT.IN PARTICULAR
WITH HIS FORMER PLANET ALLOWS
US TO TAKE THIS MODEL THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN USING LOCALLY AT
VALLEY AND A PLANT TO AN ACTUAL
STANDARD THAT CAN BE MEASURED.
THE BUDGET CYCLE PRICES EACH
TIME WE IMPLEMENT A OF BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHERE TASK.
DEMONSTRATING EXACTLY HOW THAT
PULLED OUT AND THE SUCCESS OF
IT SO THAT IS ALL IN HERE AND
CAN IN OUR REQUEST. RIGHT BUT I
DON'T. I HAVE BEEN IT IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'VE GOT THIS TEST WE
SHOULD BE SEEING IT IS
OTHERWISE YOU WOULDN'T BE
REPLICATED RIGHT. SO THAT'S ALL
I'M ASKING FOR IS JUST WITH
WITH OUR DATA. FROM THIS
EXPERIENCE AND WHY THAT SHOULD
BE TRANSFERRED. TO OTHER. IF
IT'S SUCCESSFUL GREAT BUT IF
THE WORKING MAN I DON'T WANNA
SUPPORT A PIPE DREAM. YOU KNOW.
FORGIVE ME FOR BEING A LITTLE
MORE. IN THE WEEDS WE DO SEE
THAT SUCCESS AND WE'VE SHARED
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY I'M
JUST ONE OF MANY LETTERS THAT
WE RECEIVE FROM THE- I MEAN
IT'S NOT. ENOUGH PROGRAM AND
ALSO SOME PHOTOS DEMONSTRATE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IN THE
PROGRAM AND WHILE WE'RE NOT
PREPARED HERE TODAY WITH WHAT.
RECIDIVISM THE CITY THOSE AT AS
AN- IN DO KNOW THAT WE HAVE 92%
OF THEM. ACTIVELY DISSIPATING
GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN SHARING
THEIR STORY OF HOW IT'S
TRANSFORM THEM. SO WE KNOW THAT
TO BE TRUE AND WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO DO NOW WITH
ALL OF THOSE ENTER. THEY ARE SO
FAST. GO IF YOU TAKE ALL THE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS THERE IN THIS
AGE GROUP. AND THEN. SOME OF
THEM FOR THIS PROGRAM. SO IT'S
GOING TO BE A- I GUESS OF
PROCESS TO SELECT PEOPLE. IT
WILL BE ON THIS PROGRAM FROM
THAT AGE GROUP. THEN ONCE YOU
SELECTED PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE PROGRAM. AND THEN. IN
A CERTAIN NUMBER WE'RE GOING TO
GRADUATE FROM THE PROGRAM
CORRECT BUT A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
MARK TO BOTH SIR THIS BROKE ARE
GOING TO BE. SUCCESS THAT'S
WRONG WORD BUT MAYBE A NIGHT IT
DOESN'T WORK FOR THE PROGRAM
DOESN'T WORK FOR THEM. AS IN
TERMS OF THEIR ABILITIES. SO. I
THINK YOU HAVE TO MEASURE IN
TERMS OF. HOW IT IMPACTS THE
WHOLE GROUP OF USED. YOU FOR
FENDERS THERE IN THE AGE GROUP
IN YOUR APARTMENT BUT ALSO
MEASURE THE ONES THAT ENTER.
AND WHAT KIND OF SUCCESS LIKE
HOW MANY DROPOUTS YOU HAVE THAT
WOULD BE. MANY DROPOUTS. AND
THEN. WHAT'S IF YOU GO THROUGH
THE FINAL PROGRAM AND COMPLETED
WHAT IS THE SUCCESS OF THAT
THAT SUBGROUP OF THE WHOLE. SO
I THINK YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME
VERY YOU KNOW. CUT ABOVE. YOU
KNOW FIRST SIZE THE MEASUREMENT
QUALITY CONTROL MEASUREMENT IS
WHAT. WE NEED WE DON'T NEED
ANECDOTAL KIND OF INFORMATION
THAT'S NOT. IT'S NICE BUT IT
DOESN'T. IT DOESN'T CREATE A
WAIT A VALUE WAIT A PROGRAM
CORRECTLY. FROM OUR STANDPOINT
IN THE BUDGET YEAH WE'RE
ALLOCATING MONEY HERE. SO WE
HAVE TO ALLOCATED BASED ON WHAT
WE THINK THE PROGRAM'S GOING TO
DO IN TERMS SUCCESS. THIS
SOUNDS GOOD YOU KNOW WHAT WE
WANT TO SEE SOME KIND OF
METRICS I GET. OKAY BERMAN
FINANCE COMMERCE ALSO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS GOING
TO CLARIFY DEPARTMENTS NOT
SELECTING WHICH INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATE WOULD BE MANDATORY
FOR THAT AGE GROUP GOING WE'RE-
AND ALSO THE VERGE REQUESTING
IS A ONE TIME CONTRACT.
THOUSAND TO DO EXTRA RESEARCH
TO A VSP IDENTIFY AREN'T
METRICS AND CUT ACTION MEASURE
THE- YES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
KNOWING MORE ABOUT THAT. WE
HAVE A HISTORY NICE. OUT RIGHT.
SPENDING A WHOLE LOT OUR LAST.
FOR SPENDING LESS IN GETTING A
LOT MORE THAN. OUR DEPARTMENT
AND- THE BELL YOUR STAFF OKAY
THANK YOU FROM. OKAY I INVITE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE
SIDE OF. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HELEN ROTH DOWDEN FROM SEIU
LOCAL ONE THOUSAND WE SUPPORT
THESE THESE FACILITIES WE
REALLY THINK THEY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO THE INMATES BUT
TAKING YOUR POINT WE REALLY
THINK WITH DJJ MOVING TO HAVE
I'M A THERAPEUTIC ENVIRONMENT
FOR SOME OF THE KIDS WHO MIGHT
HAVE MORAL SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS SIGNATURE THERE MIGHT
BE MORE RESOURCES ON THE DJJ
SIDE NOW THAT IT'S MOVING. OVER
THERE HHS BUT WE'RE HOPING THAT
THERE'S SOME DECISIONS MADE
WHERE YOU YOUNG MADE IF WE KNOW
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO BE DEAD IN
ALL THAT THAT WORKING WITH
COURTS TO MAKE SURE WHERE WE
HAVE THOSE EFFECTIVE RESOURCES.
EXPENSE RESOURCE AT THE-
COUNTIES REALLY CAN'T AFFORD.
THOSE KIDS WOULD GO TO THE DJJ
FACILITY WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE
MORE ACCESS PARTICULARLY ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE BUT WE THINK
YOU'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ON THIS I JUST MAKE
SURE THAT. WHERE THOSE WITH
OTHER RESOURCES ARE THAT THAT'S
WHERE DOES THIS POPULATION HAS
ALSO SENT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYBODY ELSE OKAY THANK
YOU I THINK WE'RE ALL THIS OPEN.
YOU VERY MUCH THE JOB THEY WILL
GO ON AN EXCITING MRS
TECHNOLOGY FOR INMATES
PARTICIPATING IN ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS. WE'LL HAVE THE
CATALYST COME FORWARD. THE ERIC
SIR. RIGHT OKAY. WHEN YOU HAVE
A FOR. RIGHT ERIC SWANSON I'M
DEPUTY DIRECTOR. SERVICES FOR
CDC ARE. THE SECOND REQUEST YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU TODAY IS FOR
THIRTY EIGHT POSITIONS AND
TWENTY SIX POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND ONGOING FUNDING
TO CREATE AN ACADEMIC CLOUD
NETWORK. HARDWARE TO ENHANCE
EFFICIENCY IN PROVIDING
REHABILITATIVE ACADEMIC
PROGRAMMING IN THE OFFENDER
POPULATION WITH ME TODAY IS
RYAN SUE SO WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR PROGRAM SUPPORT OF THE
DIVISION OF PEOPLE TATIAN
PROGRAMS AND ALSO ON PAGE IS
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
ENTERPRISE SYSTEMS AND PLANNING
DIVISION AT C. C. R. THANK YOU.
JOHN GOOD MORNING SIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS FRANCES AGAIN AND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF A
PROGRAM SUPPORT FOR THE
DIVISION OF RESULTED A PROGRAMS.
TODAY I'LL BE GOING OVER A
BRIEF SUMMARY OF THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU. THE DIVISION
RECENTLY EXPANDED ON A NUMBER
OF SUBJECTS INCLUDING LITERACY
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
CAREER TECHNICAL TRAINING. THIS
PROPOSAL REALLY ATTEMPTS TO
LAYER THE CRITICAL FOUNDATION
OF STANDARD TECHNOLOGY THAT
EXISTS WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND TO THE CDC OURS EDUCATIONAL
CLASSROOMS. ULTIMATELY CREEPING
MORE DOUBLE TECHNOLOGIC. WITH
THE AIM OF BETTER PREPARING THE
POPULATION IT'S LEAVING AT THE
ENTERING THE COMMUNITIES
CREASING STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
CONFIDENCE. IN TOTAL AND IS
REQUESTING FORTY THOUSAND THIN
CLIENTLAPTOPS ROLLED OUT OVER
A PERIOD OF TWO YEARS TO REALLY
COVER ALL ACADEMIC CLASSROOM
SETTINGS COVERING STUDENTS IN
LOWER LITERACY ALL THE WAY UP
TO COLLEGE LEVEL PROGRAMMING.
THESE THEN CLIENT LAPTOPS IN TO
BE AN INEXPENSIVE SOLUTION WHEN
COMBINED WITH THE PROPOSED
ENVIRONMENT. THIS PROPOSAL
SUPPORTS DEVELOPMENT OF A CLOUD
NETWORK AS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND REAL IT'S GOING
TO IMPLEMENT A LEARNING
PROCESS. ALONG ALL. AVAILABLE
TO ALL. ALL STUDENTS. THOUGHT
FOODS PROGRAMS I READING RISE.
AS TECH. IN ONLINE HIGH SCHOOL
PRESS RECOVERY. AND TESTING
SOLUTIONS. THIS SOFTWARE. IS
REALLY SET ON OUR THAT WE HAVE
NOW SITS ON COMPLEX TECHNOLOGY
AND DIFFICULT IMAGE TO MODIFY
IN VERY CLASSROOMS ACROSS THE
STATE AND SO IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GET STUDENTS BOTH ENGAGED AND A
TECHNOLOGICAL ENVIRONMENT AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT- ONE HAS
ACCESS TO IT THIS PROPOSAL
ATTEMPTS TO ACCOMPLISH ON THOSE
THOSE. YEAR'S CURRENTLY
IMPORTANT. THESE THAT THE
CLIENT LAPTOPS HAVE A PRODUCT
SUITE. THINK MICROSOFT OFFICE
OR GOOGLE DOCS AND ALLOWED.
WHICH ALLOW OUR STUDENTS TO
CHECK THEM OUT AND POTENTIALLY
WORK OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM
WHEN I'M IN THEIR CELLS I MEAN
THAT'S IN PARTICULAR. ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO COLLEGE AND
HIGH SCHOOL POPULATIONS THAT
ARE WORKING ON PAPERS ON THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY HAD TO HAND
WRITE TERM PAPERS. HANDWRITTEN
PAPERS TO THE TEACHERS THAT'S
REALLY A HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR REALLY CREATING A
STANDARD. TECHNOLOGICAL BASE
OUR STUDENT POPULATION. WELL
THIS IS AN INTENDED TO SUPPLANT
ANY FACE TO FACE INSTRUCTION.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO SUPPLEMENT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
CLASSROOMS AND REALLY GIVE OUR
STUDENTS ENVIRONMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY THE SIX. THE
COMMUNITY I'M WITH THE MOST
BASS TECHNICAL. THEY'RE GOING
TO FACE PLEASE. THINGS RIGHT
JOB MISSION. GO TO THE STATE
JOB WEBS THOSE OF BEING THAT
RIGHT NOW THEY HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO WHILE THEY'RE IN AND-
ULTIMATELY I JUST REALLY ALLOWS
OUR POPULATION TO HAVE ONE LAST
DRESSER. UPON RELEASE AND SO
THIS IS REALLY A- WE BELIEVE
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION AND THE
ENVIRONMENT WE'RE TRYING TO
DEVELOP. I'M WITH ON PAGE TWO
IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OUR
TECHNOLOGY SIDE OF CDC ARE- AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WAS ANYTHING.
MORE AT OKAY. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS IT'S SO G. E. D. COLLEGE
LEVEL. MAYBE LIFE EXPERIENCE
EDUCATION. CAN YOU GIVE ME THE
BREADTH OF THE TYPE OF PROGRAMS
THAT YOU WOULD HAVE. YES THE
OVERALL GOAL IS TO REALLY
INTEGRATE ABOUT 50% OF THE
CLASSROOM TIME INTO THIS
TECHNOLOGY BASED AND SO. WITH
THAT TECHNOLOGY BASE YOU HAVE A
LEARNING MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT
CAN GO ACROSS. EVERYONE IN
LOWER LITERACY LEVELS ALL THE
WAY UP TO COLLEGE OF A
PROGRAMMING. THINGS LIKE CANVAS
ARE BLACK FOR THE DISSIPATING
AND- IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU
HAD MENTIONED AND SPECIFICALLY.
A SOFTWARE THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL TO THE DEVELOPMENT AND
THOSE ARE THINGS LIKE READING
HORIZONS WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE
LOW AND LOWER LEVEL. FOCUS AND-
THE SOFT. INTELLIGENT A
SENSITIVE KIND OF MONITORS
PEOPLE'S RESPONSES CAN
ULTIMATELY CONTINUE DEVELOPING
QUESTIONS AROUND AREAS THAT
THEY MAY BE STRUGGLING THE SAME
GOES FOR ARE ASKED TAX SOFTWARE
THAT HELPS WITH HIGHER LEVEL
LITERACY AND AN ONLINE HIGH
SCHOOL CREDIT RECOVERY SO
REALLY THE BREADTH OF
EVERYTHING WE OFFER AN ACADEMIC
CLASSROOMS IN THE STOCK. THAT
WE HAVE. THIS THROUGHOUT THE
FUSIONS BEING IN ONE PLACE FOR
CLASSROOMS AND STUDENTS TO
ACCESS ALL THE TIME. YOU HAVE A
IS A LIKE A FOUR YEAR DEGREE
POSSIBLE OR MASTERS DEGREE.
POSSIBLE IN RECENT YEARS THE C.
R. TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN AND- TO KERR HAS REALLY
FOCUSED ON EXPANDING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE GRANT AND IN THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL AS WELL WE DO
HAVE A EXPANSION OF OUR BASS IS
TO BE PROGRAM THAT WE'VE BEEN
RUNNING AT CAL STATE LA- THAT.
HAS BEEN. THROUGH FRANCE PASSED
AWAY AND OUR ASKING TO THE NOW
PROGRAM SLIGHTLY I'M AND THAT'S
IN A PROPOSAL THIS BEFORE THIS
BODY. WHEN I WENT WOMEN'S
PRISON LAST YOUR THEY WANTED TO
HAVE A FOUR YEAR DEGREE ONLINE
PROGRAM I THINK I MENTIONED TO
YOU. CAN YOU GIVE ME A- ASTANA
SO WHERE ON WOMEN'S FACILITIES
WILL HAVE THESE PROGRAMS ALSO
BOTH OF THE WOMEN'S FACILITIES
ARE AN OFF BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
HAVE A FOUR YEAR OFFERING
SPERMATIC. OF THE LET THE
LESSER A WINNER EXPLORE ON THIS
IS. SPECIAL EDUCATION SPECIAL
EDUCATION HAS TO BE DONE%
THROUGH AN EVALUATION OF THE
PERSON. TO DETERMINE WHAT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT AS AN
AND WHAT OTHER DISABILITIES
THEY MIGHT HAVE THAT INHIBIT
THEIR EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
AND THEN A- INDIVIDUAL
EDUCATION PLAN DEVELOPED FOR
THAT PERSON IS THE PROCESS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION SO EACH
PERSON AND THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SYSTEM WILL HAVE A-
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PLAN. OF
THE EDUCATION PLAN WILL BE
SUPPLEMENTED BY. SELECT
COUNSELORS IF THEY NEED
BEHAVIORAL COUNSELING OR
EDUCATIONAL COUNSELING SPECIAL.
GROUNDS FOR A DISABILITIES SUCH
AS DYSLEXIA OR SOME OTHER KINDS
OF READING DISABILITY. OTHER
KINDS OF DISABILITIES THERE IS.
AND A DAUGHTER CLEO USE THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE EXACTLY
THE NUMBERS BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK I'VE EVER GOTTEN AN
ANSWER- THERE ARE PROBABLY A
LOT OF INMATES IN OUR
FACILITIES THAT. WE WOULD
QUALIFY AS- LEARNING DISABLED
IT PROBABLY WOULD NEED. SOME
KIND OF APPROACH LIKE THAT. ON
TO THE TERM AND WHAT THE PROPER.
PROGRAM IS IN ALL SUSAN PRETTY
GOOD. TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE FOR
PROGRAMS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
OFFER READING PROBLEMS FOR ALL
THESE KINDS OF THINGS. OF I AM
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE GROUP WE
HAVE AN IN OUR COUNTY COURT
PARENTS HELPING PARENTS AND
WERE INVOLVED IN THAT. OUR
FAMILY. OF WHICH- HAS
TECHNOLOGY. TOUR THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF READING DISABILITIES
DIFFERENT KINDS OF. PROCESSING
PROBLEMS HOPES THE STUDENT GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF LEARNING
SO HOW CAN YOU CAN YOU KIND OF
GIVE A- IDEA OF WHAT YOU THINK
WHO HOW YOU WITH A GERMAN. HOW
MANY OF YOUR INMATES WOULD BE
UNDER THIS CATEGORY IS THERE AN
IDEA. OR AND THEN WHAT KIND OF
SERVICES WHAT THEY HAVE IN THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION ARENA THAT
YOU WOULD OFFER WITH THIS
PROGRAM. SO WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
A FORMAL ASSESSMENT AT THIS
TIME TO DETERMINE- SOME OF
THOSE. THINGS THAT YOU
MENTIONED THEY DO YOU OFTEN
THERE ARE TEACHERS WILL
RESEARCH SOME OF THE-
HISTORICAL ON DOCUMENTS THAT
COME WITH THEM FROM OTHER
SCHOOLS AND SO IF THEY HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY DIAGNOSED. AND WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP I.
BASICALLY MEANT PROGRAM ANYONE
THAT WOULD. IN ADDITION THIS IS
ONE OF THE REASONS WERE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS TECHNOLOGY
BECAUSE IT IS VERY NIMBLE AND
IF WE FIND A TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTION THAT WILL OPEN
RESPECTS. WE CANNOT. THIS WHEN.
ONE SO WHAT LATE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ACT TEACHERS THAT ARE
TRAINED TO HELP IDENTIFY THESE
THINGS WELL THEY'RE NOT FORMAL
PROBABLY PSYCHOLOGIST LIKE YOU
SEE IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR SEE
AND WORK WITH YOU STRUGGLE-
WITH STUDENTS THAT MIGHT BE
ALLOWED IN THE USUAL PROCESS
NOT ONE TO PAY FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS. SO WE JUST DISPLAYING
SOME OF YOUR HE WAS IT'S REALLY
AS A RESULT OF SOME UNDERLYING
LEARNING IMPAIRMENT WE HAVE IT
IN YOUR THAT ARE FOLKS ON THE
SOUTH NO HELP HERE. THIS
LEARNERS ARE STRUGGLING AND
ALSO WE HAVE TEACHERS DEDICATED
TO. BOTH COGNITIVE AND PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES THAT TUDENTS MAY
HAVE WHERE TEACHERS CAN SAY
THIS PERSON MAY BE STRUGGLING
WITH- THE CLASSROOM AND THOSE
TEACHERS WILL ALSO HAVE ONE ON
ONE INCH WHERE THEY CAN PULL A-
STUDENTS OUT REALLY. IT'S ON
THE BURNING THAT MAY BE. WITH
YOUR NEED HELP WITH AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS REALLY GREAT
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE IS NOW THEY
CAN WALK OUT. WITH A MY LAPTOP.
AT TEACHER HAVE ONE MORE TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX TO HELP SUPPORT.
OF PEOPLE GETTING LITERACY
GAINS IN THE NUMERACY GAINS
THAT THEY NEED BEFORE THEY ARE
RELEASED. SO YOU BETTER- WE
GIVE ME SOME MORE ANSWERS ABOUT
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS AND-
PROBABLY. I WOULD GUESS. YEAH
I'D SOMEBODY WOULD CREWS. GO
LOOK AT THE SOMEBODY WOULD
PROBABLY LOOK INTO THIS FROM.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ASPECT FROM
THE AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT
IN. A YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO HAVE EQUAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR SPECIAL ED
OKAY. SO YOU HAVE TO YOU HAVE
TO SHOW. YOU KNOW HOW YOUR
PERFORMING IN TERMS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEBODY WITH
THE SPECIAL ED OR SPECIAL EDUC.
SO CENTER MORE LIKE YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. YOUR METRIC AN
HOUR WHAT ARE WHAT WILL RESPECT
YOU BUT HOW MUCH ARE WE- BROUGH
ON THAT SO JUST. NICE A. BUT
NOT NOT NOT THE NUMBERS BUT
RESULTS AND THEN WHAT ABOUT THE-
YOUR USE SOFTWARE I'M ASSUMING
YOU'RE NOT GOING ON THE
INTERNET SO THAT. THEY WON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
RIGHT THAT IS CORRECT BUT I
WILL LET DON WHO IS THE EXPERT.
PUBLISHED THE SERVICE SO THANK
YOU. WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
CREATED A AN ISOLATED NETWORK
FOR THESE MACHINES TO BE ON IT
ALLOWS US TO MANAGE ESSENTIALLY
THE CONTENT REMOTELY THE REAL
BUSINESS VALUE HERE FOR US IS
THAT- AS AS RYAN DESCRIBED WE
MANAGE THE CONTENT THAT GOES ON
THOSE MACHINES AND SO IF
THERE'S TECHNOLOGY TO US WHEN
IT. PROPERLY DEAR BE WAS
REBUILT IT PROGRAMS FOR POOR
THIS USE WE CAN. ENABLE THAT
TECHNOLOGY THROUGH THE DEVICES.
THE DEVICES ARE DEFINITELY
COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT ARE YOU
SEPARATED FROM THE INTERNET-
AND WE ONE OF THE CHECKS WE DO
FROM ON INFORMATION SECURITY
STANDPOINT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ANY. PRODUCTS WE USE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT DON'T HAVE. GATEWAY
SO TO SPEAK TO GET TO THE
INTERNET SO WE WANT TO MAKE THE
EXPERIENCE AS CONTEMPORARY AS
POSSIBLE WE OBVIOUSLY DO HAVE
LIMITATIONS WE MANAGED. AND HOW
DO YOU. YOU THAT YOU BACK AT
EACH OTHER I AS YOUR LAPTOP
YOUR- YES SO THE YES THE- SO
THE MODEL WILL BE THE THEIR
ROTATED LIKE THEY DON'T GET THE
SAME WHAT. RIGHT EQUIPMENT
EVERY. BILL BILL ACCESS THEIR
CONTENT THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CONTENT THROUGH- THROUGH A-
AGAIN ID- AS YOU AS WE
EXPERIENCE SAME THING I'M
DEVICE INDEPENDENT AND SO. AND
WE MONITOR AND MANAGE ALL THE
CASES WITH THE MOST
CONTEMPORARY AND POINT OF ICE
MANAGEMENT SOFTWARES AVAILABLE
TO US TO DO THAT SO WE CAN SEE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE DEVICE.
THANK YOU OF THANK YOU.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST COMMENTS ON
THIS ISSUE. LUCAS MORROW THAT I
OWN. WE THINK THAT THAT
PROPOSAL IS PROMISING DUE TO
THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM TO HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
BY CITIES HERE OUR- BIBLE WE
HAVE CONSERVE. COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
ESPECIALLY GIVENTHE COST. OF
AN INDICATION. WE NOTE TAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSAL
REPRESENTS A SIXTEEN PERCENT
INCREASE IN CVC OURS CURRENT
BUDGET CROCKETT EDUCATION. AND
FOR ILLUSTRATIVE PURPOSES WE
ESTIMATE THAT. COULD HIRE A- DO
YOU RATE ECONOMIC AND- ROBOT.
THIS IS TO FIFTY HUNDRED
ANNUALLY USING THIS AMOUNT OF
FUNDING. GIVEN THIS HIGH COST
WE DO RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
PROPOSAL BUT IN A CRUDE-
TRAILER BILL LEGISLATION
REQUIREMENTS CCIR TO CONTRACT
WITH AN EXTERNAL RESEARCH OR DO
AN EVALUATION OF THE COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS IMPROVING.
OUTCOMES IN THE- RELATIVE TO
CLASSROOM BASED INSTRUCTION AND
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE ALLEGED
CHOI CHOIR THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE. EVALUATION OF THE
PROGRAM NO LATER THAN TEN
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR WE GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAM AND PHONE ABOUT IT
SHOULD BE. THIS THEN GIVE. YOU
NEED TO GO ABOUT IT. THANK YOU
IT. STAFF RESPONSIBILITY OF ANY
RESPONSE. WHAT THEY SAID THE
FORMER FINANCE. IN REGARDS TO
FOURTEEN DEMONSTRATIONS OPEN
DISCUSSING IDEAS WITH ALLEGED
LEGISLATURE REGARDING USE FOR
FORTY METRICS HOWEVER THE
MINISTRATION WANT TO EVALUATE
WHAT DENNIS CURLYCOLLECTED AND
ASSESSING IN FISCAL IMPACTS THE
DEPARTMENT. ALSO REFERENCES OF
BILL'S COMMENT ABOUT TO AN
ADDITIONAL INSTRUCTORS AND THE
CONCERN IS THAT NOT INTENDED
BCP OTHER BUSY BEES MENTALLY
ENHANCED EXPERIENCE OF THE
INMATES TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
MORE PROGRAMMING AND THERE ARE
TIMES TO DO. THIS WORK. BAD
THERE IS. HI TO SPACE IN
COMPUTER LABS AND OVERALL JUST
DOESN'T ENHANCE THAT INMATES.
EDUCATION. I'M TO CARVE OUT A
COMMENT ON THAT WAS JUST FOR
ILLUSTRATIVE PURPOSES OF HOW
THIS MONEY COULD BE USED
ALTHOUGH A SKYROCKETING PRODUCT
EDUCATION NOT RECOMMENDED TO
INSTRUCTORS. OKAY QUESTION. ON
THAT- WHEN I WHEN I VISITED A
LOT OF THE SOUL IS A- THE BIG
CLASSES AND I BE IN THE CLASS
AND ALSO IN. THE ALARM GO OFF
AND- THE BILL WOULD HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THEIR CELLS AND- IT
HAPPENS FREQUENTLY RIGHT
INTERRUPTIONS. THIS THIS IS
MORE FLEXIBLE TO AVOID THAT
COULD YOU YOU TALK ABOUT. IN
THE CLASSROOM KIND OF VERSES
THIS APPROACH HELLO HOW YOU MIX
THE TWO TOGETHER. MAYBE A
MEASURE YEAH YEAH YEAH LIKE
BECAUSE IN TERMS OF OPERATING-
IN A FACILITY IN TRYING TO
EDUCATE THE INMATES AS I WAS IN
SOME WERE THERE. THERE IS A BUT
EVERY TIME AFTER TIME THERE IN
THE CLASSIC GOT INTERRUPTED.
THE SEVENTH SEAL IS SO WE'RE
DOING IN THE DIVISION OF REAL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS WERE
DOING TWO THINGS TO HELP.
MITIGATE SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
ONE WE ARE TRACKING IN DETAIL
ALONG WITH OUR PARTNERS IN THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS-
BASICALLY CLASSROOM ATTENDANCE
SO ANYTIME WHERE A STUDENT
WOULD HAVE TO EXIT THE
CLASSROOM FOR A PARTICULAR
PURPOSE. ALL TEXT REVIEW THAT
WITH OUR COUNTERPARTS TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO TRY AND
MITIGATE THOSE ISSUES THAT MAY
BE CAUSING THOSE DISTRACTIONS.
BUT TO GO TO THE LARGER POINT
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN THE-
AND- THE CONTEXT IN WHICH
YOU'RE LAYING THE QUESTION TO
SAY. IF SOMEBODY HAS A COMPUTER
OR THIN CLIENT LAPTOP CHECKED
OUT TO THEM THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY IF THEY'RE WALKING OUT
OF THAT CLASS OF GOING BACK TO
THEIR CELL. SIMPLY CLOSE THAT
BOOKED AND WALK INTO THE
CLASSROOM. WORKING OFFLINE AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
MAY BE WORKING ON A CLASS BACK
LATER COME BACK LATER AND- YOU
WENT. I'M THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY THAT EXISTS WITH
THESE MODELS THAT ALLOW. TO GET
A- TIME IT BEFORE. I'M PEOPLE
WERE TO LEAVE OUR SET LIST ON
THAT TOPIC. WHEN YOU'RE OUT
THAT ROOM. WELL DO YOU. MANY
TIMES THE CLASSES ARE. THE SOME.
THE BODY DOES WE DO YES
CONTINUOUS. WILL THE MEASURE OF
THE POINT I'M MAKING IS. WITH
THIS REDUCE THAT- DO. THIS
EDUCATE. LAST CLASSROOM
TEACHERS I WOULD THINK IT MOST
PEOPLE THINK IT WOULD BE
SUPERIOR TO HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE TEACHER
ABOUT THAT SAME TIME. THE
CLASSROOMS ERUPTED ALL THE TIME
THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING EITHER
SO WE ARE NOT LOOKING TO
SUPPLANT THE FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION WE DON'T WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION. BUT WITH THAT
ALLOWS THE TOOL TO BASICALLY
ALLOW THAT TO CONTINUE SO I
WILL STUDENTS WORK ON THIS SIDE
THE CLASSROOM YES WOULD BE
AVOID GOING PAST USES LAPTOPS
NOT THE GOAL GOAL IS TO REALLY
ENTER SO THAT THEY HAVE. A LOT
KNOWLEDGE. ONCE SOME OF.
FURTHER IF ON THIS SOME WAY
THANK YOU SURE I THINK YOU CHEN
AS PROGRESS TO OUR
REHABILITATION FOCUS WE'VE BEEN
OFFERING MORE MORE PROGRAMS AND
CLASSES IN YOUR RIGHT YOU KNOW
SORT OF HAVE A- LIMITED IN
TERMS OF SPACE. WHAT WE CAN DO
BUT ALSO BE. WE ARE TRYING TO
TECHNOLOGY IN AGAIN THAT WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO SUPPLANT THE
EDUCATION CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE.
BUT WE'VE TRIED TO EXPAND
PROGRAMMING INTO. THIRD WATCH
AND OTHER AREAS OF THE WERE
USING WHAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE.
FOR THE MAX AMOUNT OF TIME
POSSIBLE. YEAH I CAN PROVIDE
SOME A WRITTEN STATEMENT OKAY
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON THIS ISSUE PLEASE.
ONE ROTH DOESN'T REPRESENTING
SEIU LOCAL ONE THOUSAND THE
TEACHERS. IN YOU KNOW WE SEE
THIS IS POSITIVE BUT WE YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO LOOK AT HOW THE
STUDENTS ARE MANY OF THEM HAVE
NOT HAD A SUCCESS. IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHAT IS SIXTY PERCENT-
ARE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES OF BY
REMEMBER. MANY OF OUR TEACHERS
TELL US ONE OF OUR MATH
TEACHERS FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY DO THEY PUT
NOT MEANT THREE. ON THE BOARD
AND SEE HOW MANY PEOPLE COME UP
WITH I'M I'M SORRY SIX AND
THREE ON THE BOARD AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE COME UP WITH NINE IS
ANSWER IT. COME UP WITH TWELVE.
THEY'RE JUST SICK. THE WAY
HOPING. YOU KNOW THAT THEIR
OFTEN THIS ISSUE YES AS THIS
WILL GIVE TIME FOR MORE ONE ON
ONE INSTRUCTION. I'M THE HOURS
IN THE CLASS CAN HAVE GONE DOWN
WE ARE FULLY PART OF A- WE CAN.
THIS SOME OF THE BUSINESSES.
AROUND IS WITH. FOCUS THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EXTRA. WE
THINK THIS BE POTS. WE DON'T
THINK BRINGING THIS PRO. IN FOR
EXAMPLE USING IT. FOR AN
INSTRUCTOR ONE FACILITY TO BE
TEACHING AT ANOTHER FACILITY A
SOMETHING WHAT WILL WORK. BUT
THE IDEA OF HAVING THIS THAT
COULD EXTEND ON. WHAT THEY
LEARNED IN THE CLASSROOM THE
OTHER TIME WHEN THEY'RE NOT
LIKELY. ZERO A POD. WORD AND
THE INTERNET. WITHIN THE I MEAN
THAT'S REALLY GOING TO BE. UP
REALLY MIND BLANK. INSTEAD THEY
NEED THIS SO WITH THAT WE HAVE
SOME TREPIDATION OF NOT
REPLACING TEACHERS ON THE OTHER
HAND WE FEEL IT'S A REALLY
POSITIVE MOVE TO ALLOW THIS
TECHNOLOGY AN INMATE WILL BE
WORKING WITH ONCE THEY GET OUT
OF PRISON AND MOST OF THEM ALL
Q. THE- TEACHER. IT PRISON-
SPONSORED THE- DO THEY HAVE
LIKE A SPECIAL ED CREDENTIAL OR-
IS THAT A REQUIREMENT. THERE'S
SO MANY PEOPLE THAT HAD THE
DISABILITIES SORRY. ASIA YOU
HAVE TEACHERS THAT DO HAVE
SPECIAL ED CREDENTIALS MOST OF
THEM HAVE- MULTIPLE MULTIPLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL- AND SOME
OTHER CREDENTIALS BUT YES THERE
ARE TEACHERS IN OUR SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IF YOU WERE
IN A REGULAR SCHOOL YOU- A
WORTHY GOAL. CATION AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS TO A TEACHERS TRAINED
TO DEVELOP CITY AND IF THEY CAN
DEVELOP IF YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
DEVELOPING AN EDUCATION PLAN
THAT DEALS WITH THE INDIVIDUALS
DISABILITIES THEN YOU CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR- CHIANG.
AND THEIR PROGRAM FOR THE
CHILD- THE BIRTH THE CHILD IN
ME. YOU WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMENT ON THAT I WOULD JUST
SAY YOU MIGHT ASK YOU KNOW HOW
THE NUMBERS BUT BUDGET XIN
TEACHERS WITH AN- WE'VE WE'VE
HAD ONGOING DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE UNDER OF THE I. D.
E. A. UNTIL. AGE TWENTY TWO.
AND HOW THAT HAPPENS WITHIN YOU
KNOW THAT IT HAPPENS A DJJ BUT
IT'S NOT REALLY DOESN'T HAPPEN
IN THESE INSTITUTIONS AS MUCH
AS WE COULD BE LOOKING AT IT SO
YOU MIGHT WANNA LOOK AT THAT IS
AN AREA OF INQUIRY. THANK YOU
OKAY ANY LIKE TO. ANYBODY ELSE
WHAT DO ADDRESSES ON THIS ISSUE
OKAY CENTER OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ONE OF THE EXCITING-
CORRECTIONAL VIDEO SURVEILLANCE.
DRUG INTERDICTION- PROJECT
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE THE NEXT
GROUP COME UP PLEASE. AND WE
GOT ERIC SWANSON'S GONNA
LEADERS I GUESS. RIGHT THE NEXT
REQUEST IS FOR TWENTY ONE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANY POSITIONS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWO ONE MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND SIX POSITIONS
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. GOING
TO ENHANCE DRUG INTERDICTION
EFFORTS BY COMPLETING
ADDITIONAL DEPLOYMENTS. OF OUR
CORRECTIONAL VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
PROJECT WHICH WE STARTED. AT
HIGH DESERT. THE PRISONS WE'D
LIKE TO ADD A RICHARD J.
DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
SALINAS VALLEY STATE PRISON.
AND THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION
FOR WOMEN. WITH ME IS MARION
SPEARMAN WHO'S THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS AND JOHN
PAGE FROM THE LAST ISSUE.
MORNING CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS OF
PANEL IS MERION BERMAN
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE JEEP
EMAIL PRISONS MY EYES WHEN I
JUST GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
HOW OUR DEPARTMENT BENEFIT.
FROM NATIONAL VIDEOS TAYLOR IS
TO THE THREE. INSTITUTIONS THAT.
PENSION WHAT MADE YOU FROM
FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN AFTER WE
IMPLEMENT VIDEO SURVEILLANCE AT
THE HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON
AND THAT IS CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S FACILITY. I WAS ABLE TO
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY INCIDENTS OF
VIOLENCE. IN SEVERAL CASES THE
VIDEO EVIDENCE WAS ABLE TO BE
USED IN CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS
AND WITHIN OUR INTERNAL INMATE
DISPONER PROCESS. WITHOUT THAT
VIDEO EVIDENCE IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO PURSUE CONVICTIONS
AND IF DISCIPLINE BECAUSE
INMATES MAY BE HESITANT TO
TESTIFY BUT IT MAY BE COMPLEX
TESTIMONY BIGGER SURVEILLANCE
CAN BE CRITICAL ENSURING THESE
INCIDENTS ARE DEALT WITH FAIRLY.
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE ALSO HELPS
TO IDENTIFY AND IS A ILLEGAL
DRUGS AND GET INTO OUR
INSTITUTIONS. AS YOU TO
NUMEROUS PRESENT YOU FIVE IN
TOTAL ILLEGAL DRUGS CAN LEAD TO
VIOLENCE AN OVERDOSE DEATHS
WHICH- OUR DEPARTMENT TRULY
TRIES TO. TAKE PLACE USING
BILLS OF AS THE DENTIST BY THAT
DRUGS HOW DRUGS INTO ENTER INTO
OUR PRISONS CAN HELP US TO
PREVENT INJURY BY IN ORDER BY.
TO SUPPORT US IN OUR EXPANDED
DRUG TREATMENT. VIDEO SERVICE
ALSO HELPS IS UNFORTUNATELY
WHEN EMPLOYEES NEED TO BE
DISCIPLINED FOR BRINGING IN
CONTRABAND INSTITUTIONS. AND
ALSO IT HELPS US WHEN WE CAN
TRAIN OUR EMPLOYEES. BIGGEST
EVENTS CAN ALSO HELP WAS. IN
MADE GRIEVANCE FOR US OF
SOMEONE SAYS THAT SOMEONE HAS
DONE SOMETHING IN WEAKENED
THOROUGHLY REVIEW. THE
INVESTIGATION WE CAN USE VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE POSSIBLY WAS
CAPTURED ON CAMERA. FROM FISCAL
YEARS TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN OUR DEPARTMENT
PROSECUTED TWENTY SIX EMPLOYEES
NINER IN TWENTY FIVE VISITORS
AND A HUNDRED NOT NINETY ONE
NINE VISITORS PRETENDING TO AND
USE DRUGS ALCOHOL OR SOME OTHER
TYPE OF COLONIAS. CONTRABAND
INTO OUR STATE PRISONS. THOSE
VIDEOS ARE VIDEO RECALL.
SERVICE EVIDENCE AND LOCAL
ADMINISTRATIVE INQUIRIES THE
MINISTRY OF CIVIL AND CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS. AND WE STORE VIDEO
FOOTAGE FOR UP TO NINETY DAYS.
THE SURVEILLANCE FOR RECORDING
CAN ALSO HELP WITH DAILY
MANAGEMENT AN INSTITUTION IF
SOMETHING IS STOLEN OR
SOMETHING'S LOSS IS A TOOL
THAT. CAN USED TO DO THEIR
BREAD ASSESSMENT AND WE CAN DO
IT PRETTY QUICKLY WITHOUT US
HAVING TO LOCK DOWN THE PRISON
INTO. PEARL MANGLE SEARCHES
WHEN WE FIND OUT THAT SOMEONE
DID BRING SOMETHING IN WE FIND
OUT HOW. WE DO IT FIND THE
ACTUAL. IS RE PRISONS POLLS
WHICH BECAUSE IT DIFFERENT
PHYSICAL DESIGNS EMISSIONS
ONESELF WOMEN'S FACILITY ONCE A
RECEPTION CENTER REMAINS COMMON
INSTITUTIONS AND ONE IS A
FACILITY THAT HAS IMPACTED
MENTAL HEALTH TREAT. WELL
LARGER. MOST OF THE VIDEO
SERVICE IN DIVERSE ENVIRONMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT ALSO WISHES TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ARE RAISED
FIVE ENDERS WHEN SOMEONE SAYS
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING THAT.
INSTALLATION OF THE THESE THREE
PRISONS AGAIN WILL ASSIST US IN
ITS INVESTIGATION OF BOY
MISCONDUCT BROUGHT FOR MY
INTEREST BROUGHT OR BY VISITORS
BOB FOR BY ANOTHER EMPLOYEE.
INTO TO SUBSTANTIATE THE
MISCONDUCT TOOK PLACE OR TO
EXONERATE SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
FALSELY ACCUSE. WHEN ACT
VIOLENCE OCCUR WITH VIDEO
CAMERAS ARE INSTALLED I HEARING
A FACIAL TO MAKE. INFORMED
DECISIONS ON WHAT TOOK PLACE
AND I CAN GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT WERE PERSON MIGHT TELL
HEARING IT SHOWS THAT THEY WERE
DEFENDING THEMSELVES AND
CHECKED HIMSELF. RESULTED IN IF
THE VIDEO FOOTAGE SHOWS THAT IN
A HEARING OFFICIALS TO MAKE AN
OF POINTLESS ASIAN AND POSSIBLY
A WHITE IS MISSED THE ACTUAL
RULES VIOLATION REPORT. IN
ADDITION THE US OF WILL PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY PLEA CURRENCY FOR
DEPARTMENT WHEN ALLEGATIONS.
COME UP AGAINST EMPLOYEES AND
IT WILL POSSIBLY INFLUENCE AN
EMPLOYEE OR DEFINITELY OF
ANDERS. WHO MIGHT BE LEERY TO
VIOLATE POLICY KNOWING THAT
THEIR ACTIONS COULD BE CAPTURED
ON VIDEO. HOW MANY OF PEOPLE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS.
ARE USING OR DICK INDOOR
ADDICTED. IT'S MORE OF INMATES
ORDER WHAT WOULD WHAT WHAT KIND
OF NUMBERS YOU HAVE ON THE- OR
DO STUDY THAT YEAH I MEAN IF
YOU RECALL LAST DURING THE LAST
BUDGET CYCLE ONE OF OUR MAJOR
PROPOSALS WAS THE- I. S. UT T.
I'M- STANCHION. AND I THINK I
DON'T HAVE THE FIGURES IN FRONT
OF ME BUT I CAN GET THEM FOR
YOU I THINK AS PART OF THAT ONE
OF THE BIG HOLES WE SAW WAS.
WE'RE DOING INCREASED WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY WHAT WE NEED TO DO
BUT- WE'RE GETTING TOO MANY.
INTO THE PRISONS THEMSELVES WE
HAVEN'T DEALT WITH THAT ISSUE-
THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING THE- WILL
YOU TELL US THE PRISONER RIGHT.
SO WHAT IS THE COME UP TO ME
WHAT'S NUMBER. WHAT WOULD. TO
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM A LITTLE BIT YEAH. OKAY
YEAH WE CAN GET TO WITH. IN A
COMMA SO THEY'LL YOU'LL PLEASE
ONE O'NEILL AT THE LA L. WE
THINK THAT VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
EVERYTHING IS REASONABLE THAT
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE WOULD HELP
PROVIDE OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE WITH
WHICH TO EVALUATE IN MADE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST A STAFF.
WHICH IT APPEARS THAT THESE
THREE PRESIDENTS DO YOU HAVE A
PARTICULAR. CHALLENGES WITH I'M
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
EXTERNAL EVALUATION OF VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE AT ONE PRISON
FOUND THAT IT. BUT IN
SUGGESTING VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
CAN REDUCE USE OF FORCE AGAINST
INMATES AD INMATE ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST STAFF USE OF FORCE AND
DISCORD MEANT. SO THAT IS WHY
REYES TURNS UP. THERE THANK YOU
WE'RE ADDING EIGHT POSITIONS
PERMANENT AND YOU WON YOUR ARE
THEY JUST SIT AND WATCH THE-
YOUR THEIR EARLY. DO INSTALL
WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE WE WHAT ARE
WE GETTING. ANY WITH THE VIDEO
THAT WOULD THERE BE A CHANCE
REDUCE OTHER STAFF SEVERAL
STOPS AT. TO THE RESOURCES. IN
THIS BUDGET REQUEST ARE
ESSENTIALLY THE STAFF TO MANAGE
EQUIPMENT SO THE BUDGET REQUEST
THAT ESTABLISHED VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE THE PREVIOUS BROWN
ADMITTED TERM RESOURCES APPLIED
TO THAT. AND AS WE- THE NUMBER
OF LOCATIONS AND I'M AND
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ACTUAL. PHYSICAL
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT DEPLOYED.
THE RESOURCES ARE ESSENTIALLY
TO MANAGE- THE. THE CAMERAS
THEMSELVES THE SERVER WOMEN
THAT COLLECTS THE VIDEO CONTENT.
IN SOME STAFF AREAS WITH WITH
RESPECT TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT.
ACTUAL MONITORING OF THE VIDEO
IN SOME STAFF AREAS VIDEO. IS
MONITORED LIVE IN MANY AREAS IS
NOT IS NOT INTENDED TO BE- SORT
OF A- WATCHING STAFF TO SPEAK
IT'S MORE INTENDED TO BE AS-
ESSE SPEARMAN. REFERENCED THE
TOOL TO ADJUDICATE IS AFTER THE
FACT SO THE BUDGET CHANGE
DOESN'T ASK FOR RESOURCES TO
USE FOR. WATCH. RIGHT TAXPAYERS
BERBER HIRING EIGHT PEOPLE. HOW
TO INSTALL EQUIPMENT TO
MAINTAIN MY- THAT'S RIGHT SIR
SO MAINTAINING EQUIPMENT AT. AN
INMATE IN THE CITY'S
MAINTAINING HARDWARE SOFTWARE
THAT RUN. EQUIPMENT AFTER AND
BY WORKING EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS IT'S GOOD TO HAVE.
NUMBER IS IN GOT EVERYWHERE SO
THE NEWS IS SHOWING US VIDEOS.
I'M ALL KINDS OF MANAGER
APPOINT. ARE ACCIDENTS THAN YOU
KNOW THURMOND HE DOES ALL THE
TIME BUT- IT IS- I WILL BENEFIT
FROM THAT OTHER THAN HAVING
GOOD DOCUMENTATION BUT- AND WE
REDUCE MATT OUR SOME MORALE SO
YOU HAVE AN OFFSET. WELL THE AT
LEAST THE IS THE INTENT OF THIS
BUDGET REQUEST AS AN TO REDUCE
ANY STAFF. YOU KNOW WITH SUCH
SPECIALLY IN THE QUESTION. YEAH
I THINK GENERAL THE THIS IS A
NEW ACTIVITY THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'VE DONE BEFORE AND WE'RE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE- MISTER
SPEARMAN WHO WAS THE WARDEN AT
HIGH DESERT WHEN IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED HE NOW WORKS AT
HEADQUARTERS WE ARE EXPERIENCE
WE NEED TO HAVE- THIS THAT CAN
CONTAIN THE CAMERAS THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY ARE
LITERALLY ALL OVER THE PRISON
THEMSELVES AND THEN ALSO. THE
WORK BRING TO THE STANDARDS THE
PROPOSAL ITSELF WHICH IS WE
HAVE THE CERTAIN. NINETY DAY
PERIOD WHERE WE MAINTAIN THE
VIDEO. IN AND WE'RE NOT LOOKING
AT THE VIDEO SURE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CATCH EVERYTHING WE
HAVE TO HAVE SORT OF TRIGGERING
EVENTS THAT ALLOW US TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE VIDEO ALL OF THAT
TO OUR EXPERIENCE HAS US OF. I
BELIEVE THAT THE SUSPENSION
WORK NEW POSITION. YEAH I'M I'M
JUST TURNED ABOUT. NO THE- BUT
JUST THE STAFFING AND THE COST
OUR PRISONS RIGHT NOW- YOU KNOW
YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING THAT
AS A COROLLARY IMPACT FOR YOU
THE TICKET WE IMPLEMENT THE
FOLLOWING. OLOGY WE'RE SAVING
STAFF AND SO THAT'S JUST WHAT I
AM LOOKING FOR THAT'S FOR MIGHT
BRING IT. THANK. YOU TALK ABOUT
THE VIDEOS TERMS OF HOW IT
AFFECTS SO. TECHNOLOGY LIKE
THINGS LIKE THAT HOW DOES THE-
PLEASE. I MIGHT BE RECESSED SIR
YEAH BECAUSE WHEN I WAS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR WE HAD A
COUNTY JAIL IS. FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN A- WE HAD A
GUY. WAS THAT A FIELD ACTUALLY
PLAY GOLF SO YOU TO THE GOLF
BALLS OVER THE FENCE. THE GOLF
BALLS WERE OR OF DRUGS. SO THEY
FINALLY FOUND OUT THE GOLF
BALLS THAT WERE HIT OVER. OVER
THE FENCE WERE. DRUGS WERE USED
BY THE PRISONERS. BUT THE
DRONES SAYING IS THAT THE VIDEO
CAMERAS HOW DO I DO. YOU'RE
GONNA COME UP AND ASK FOR IT
ARE DETECTION NEXT. OKAY COULD
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT WE MAKE WE
MAKE DUG IN FUTURE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
CONTRABAND INTERDICTION THEM.
TO DO IT BROWN'S THIS
PARTICULAR REQUEST SO I REQUEST
CAMERAS BE PLACED IN HIGH
TRAFFIC AREAS YEARS OF
CONGREGATION YEAH. INSTITUTIONS
WHAT IT WILL DO FOR US WITH
RESPECT TO THAT TYPE OF
CONTRABAND COMING IN. IS OF THE
CAMERAS MAY PICK UP. THE
OCCURRENCE OF SOMETHING COMING
INTO THE PRISON GROUNDS PICK UP
THE OCCURRENCE OF- OFFENDER. IN
TOWARD THOSE AREAS. THANKS UP
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE THAT TYPE
ACTIVE. THE POSITIONING OF THE
CAMERAS IS NOT IT IS NOT SORT
OF AIM SKY WORD IF YOU WILL. IN
ORDER TO SERVE THE DETECTIVE
THIS PRIVATE IS IT A CRIME TO
PUT IT ON OVER THE- KLAY LEGAL
REALLY IS NOT. SHOULD I DON'T
THINK WE WANT OUT RIGHT. PLEASE
AND I WOULD SAY THAT'S OF THE
LOOK AND OKAY WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT- WE
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE. THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU. GOING TO ALLOW
CERTAIN. THAT'S THE
CORRECTIONAL STAFF TRAINING AND
JOB SHADOWING PROPOSAL AND
SWANSON'S GONNA LEAVE
PRESENTATION ERROR. HELLO TO US.
STAFF PROPOSED A WELCOME. OKAY
YEAH THE FOR OUR A FINAL
PROPOSAL FOR TODAY'S REQUEST
FOR TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
FIFTY FOUR POSITIONS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AN
ONGOING FUNDING AS DESCRIBED IN
THE AGENDA TO IMPROVE
DEPARTMENTAL TRAINING OF
INSTITUTIONAL BASE COST CUTS
THE STAFF BASICALLY THERE'S
FOUR COMPONENTS TO THIS
PROPOSAL BURKE TING A NEW FIRST
THE FOR RUNS ON TRAINING AT A
FOR. PER NORTHERN SO. I JUST
WHEN PROGRAM FOR NEW CORRECTION
WHILE. GIVE ADDITIONAL RC POST
REQUEST AND ADDITIONAL TRAINING
FOR CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS.
WITH ME STACEY LOPEZ WHO IS THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE PEACE
OFFICER SELECTION AN EMPLOYEE
DEVELOPMENT. AND AM RIDEAU BUT
DIO WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COMMISSION ON
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
STANDARDS AND TRAINING WHICH IS
A VERY LARGE. I DON'T. OKAY I
DON'T. OKAY THE AGENDA FOR THE
MORE YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
I'M STACY LOPEZ I'M THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OVER THE PIECE OFF
THEIR SELECTION AN EMPLOYEE
DEVELOPMENT. WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RECRUITING
HIRING AND TRAINING OF ALL
PEACE OFFICERS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. BEGINNING IN
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN MYSELF AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DUMB AND I
BEGAN CANVASSING INSTITUTIONS
OVER TWENTY FIVE- CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING ONSITE INTERVIEWS
WITH NEW CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
THEIR SUPERVISORS AND
INSTITUTIONAL MINISTRY THERE'S
TO COLLECT FEEDBACK. ON
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROVING
BOTH BASIC ACADEMY TRAINING AN
ANNUAL FIELD GETTING. THIS
PROPOSAL WAS DEVELOPED AS A
RESULT OF OUR SITE VISITS AND
JUST REGARDING TRAINING NEEDS
OF NEW STAFF AND FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS. THE
RESPONSES OVERWHELMINGLY
INDICATED CADETS THE MORE HANDS
ON REALITY BASED TRAINING TO BE
BETTER PREPARED TO PERFORM
BASIC REX OFFICER TASKS. WELL
THE CURRENT ACADEMY TRAINING
PROVIDE SOME HANDS ON REALITY
BE STRAINING CORRECTIONAL
TRAINING CENTER IS NOT DESIGNED
AS A PRISON. WHICH LIMITS THE
REALITY BASED TRAINING.
ADDITIONALLY NEW OFFICERS NEED
A PERIOD OF ORIENTATION AND JOB
SHADOWING TO BECOME CONFIDENT
AND COMPETENT IN THEIR JOB
ASSIGNMENTS. OTHER SPECIFIC
INSTITUTE PRIOR TO SIGN POST.
THE CURRENT BASIC CORRECTION
OFFICER COUNTY DOES NOT DO THE
BEST JOB OF PROVIDING A NEW
OFFICER WITH UNDERSTOOD. I'M
ADDRESS THE GOOD JOB. LET ME
CORRECT THAT AND SINCE I AM
OVER THE ECONOMY. THE CURRENT
BASIC RITUALS ACADEMY DOES A
GREAT JOB OF PROVIDING A NEW
OFFICER UNDERSTANDING OF
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS
DEPARTMENTAL POLICY PROCEDURES
A FOUNDATION OF UNDERSTANDING
IN THE USE OF EQUIPMENT AND USE
OF COURSE OPTIONS.
CERTIFICATION A PEACE OFFICER
STATUS. BASIC COMMUNICATION
SKILLS BASIC ETHICS AND BASIC
SAFETY GUIDELINES THIS HERBAL
DOES FIVE CRITICAL THINGS
EXPANDS THE USE OF THE FORMER
WOMEN'S INSTITUTION IN
STOCKTON. READING A VENUE TO
TRAIN CORRECTION OFFICERS IN A
SETTING CONDUCIVE TO THE DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS OF AN
INSTITUTION OR REAL TIME
PRACTICAL APPLICATION OF THE
CIOS JOB RESPONSIBILITY WE
SIMULATED. TEACH SPONTANEOUS
DECISION MAY. INDICATE TO USE
YES. NEED APPLICATION OF OPTION
EXCEL. THIS OUT THIS PROPOSAL
ALSO ADD. A NEW EMPLOYEE. BOB
SHUDDERING WITH WILL ALLOW THE
OFFICE TO LEARN THE LOCAL
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES OF
THEIR INSTITUTION UNDERSTAND
ITS MISSION PROGRAMS AN INMATE
POPULATION AND ACCLIMATE TO
THEIR ENVIRONMENT PRIOR TO
BEING ASSIGNED THEIR PERMANENT
POST. IT ALSO INCREASES
STOPPING FOR OUR IN SERVICE
TRAINING OFFICES DUE TO
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
NEW PROGRAM WITH ANY WITH A NEW
PLAYER TATIAN JOB SHADOWING WE
ALSO ARE WERE COSTING TO
ADDITIONAL WE COULD TRAINING
FOR CORRECTIONAL THIRDS WHICH
WILL MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT THEY
HAVE ON THEIR SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION INTO SOCIETY WITH
THE FOCUS ON. TAKE THE CASE
PLANNING ENCOURAGING COUNCIL.
OR ACTION AND COMMUNICATION
JUST TO NAME A FEW. AND FINALLY
THIS PROPOSAL IS REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES OR THE
COMMISSION ON THE SAUCER
SELECTION AND TRAINING OTHER.
ALSO NOTICE YOU POST TO ENSURE
THAT IS CRITICAL FUNCTIONS FOR
PENAL CODE ARE CARRIED OUT IN
AN EXPEDITIOUS AND THOUGHTFUL
MANNER- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
I. KNOW THAT WHEN I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS. LOUVRE
OFFICE. I WE THINK THAT THE
VARIOUS TRAINING INITIATIVES IN
THE PROPOSAL I DO GENERALLY
APPEAR TO BE WORTHWHILE BUT WE
DO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OR REJECT THE CIVIC
COMPONENTS OF THE REQUESTED
RESOURCE HAS BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T FULLY JUSTIFIED. THOSE
ARE ONE SEVEN INSTRUCTOR
POSITIONS FOR TRAINING THAT
HASN'T BEEN DEVELOPED YET AND
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT IT WOULD.
GENERALLY DO AND- THERE FOR
WHAT IT'S BENEFIT WOULD BE
RELATIVE TO ITS ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL COST. I'M
TO WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
ELEVEN OF THE FIFTEEN REQUESTED
MAINTENANCE POSITIONS FOR THE
NEW TRAINING FACILITY. BECAUSE
WE THINK THAT THAT MAINTENANCE
PACKAGES UNNECESSARILY LARGE.
THREE WE RECOMMEND REJECTING
THE OUTSIDE PATROL SERGEANT AT
THE FACILITY- BECAUSE IT'S
UNCLEAR WHY THE FACILITY WOULD
NEED THAT LEVEL OF SECURITY. IN
THE FOURTH RELATES TO THE
THIRTY FIVE A REQUESTED
SERGEANT POSITIONS OR ONE PER
PRISON THAT WOULD GENERALLY
SUPPORT. AS STAFF TRAINING
INITIATIVES ARE WORK AT THE
PRISONS AND WE THINK THAT
THIRTEEN OF THOSE THIRTY FIVE
POSITIONS ARE JUSTIFIED GIVEN
THAT THAT WORKLOAD IS. DRIVEN
BY. NEW WORKLOAD THAT WOULD
COME THROUGH WITH IF THIS
PROPOSAL IS PROPOSED. I'M
HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT HAS SAID
THAT THE OTHER TWENTY TWO
POSITIONS WOULD GO TOWARD
SUPPORTING EXISTING WORKLOAD
THAT CURRENT STAFF ARE UNABLE
TO COMPLETE IN A TIMELY MANNER.
ESSENTIALLY WE VIEWED AND DOES
THAT TWENTY TWO POSITION
REQUEST AS MENTALLY IN A
SEPARATE OR NEW PROPOSAL THAT
DIDN'T COME WITH- THE TYPE OF
JUSTIFICATION. THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO SEE FOR RESOURCE
REQUEST FOR EXAMPLE DATA
IDENTIFYING CIVIC WORKLOAD
BEING DELAYED AND THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT DELAY I'M-
AND ANALYSIS DEMONSTRATING THAT
TWENTY TWO POSITIONS ARE NEEDED
TO COMPLETE THAT WORKLOAD IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND AS WELL AS-
WHAT ALTERNATIVE THE DEPARTMENT
CONSIDERED. TO ACCOMMODATE THE
WORKLOAD. I'M IN TOTAL AFTER AT
FULL IMPLEMENTATION IF FOUR
COMPONENTS AS WE SAID WE
RECOMMEND OUR REJECTED THAT
WOULD. MEAN THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD I'M WOULD NEED FORTY TWO
FEWER POSITIONS OUT OF THE
EIGHTY FIVE REQUESTED AND AN
ASSOCIATE AND- SIX POINT SEVEN.
MILLION FEWER DOLLARS. RELATIVE
THE. FOR WHAT'S- THAT. AND THEN
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE LAW
DIRECT THAT TO PROVIDE AN
ANNUAL ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON TRAINING
OUTCOMES THAT WOULD BE EXPECTED
TO BE IMPACTED BY THESE
INITIATIVES. THE SERVICE SIX
MILLION LESS. SIX POINT SEVEN
MILLION LAST. AS OPPOSED TO
FORTY EIGHT. F. FORTY TWO FEWER
POSITIONS OUT OF AN EIGHTY
EIGHTY FIVE TOTAL AND SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FEWER- TO
REQUEST THE- WHEN YOU LOOK AT
EIGHTY FIVE ELDERLY TWO YEARS
FROM NOW RIGHT. ANDERSON OUR
ONE YEAR. THIS IS WHERE
NINETEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION. I
LIKE THE COMMENT ALSO ON A
REGARDING THE FACILITY THE
FORMER INSTITUTIONS ARE SHUT
DOWN SINCE TWO THOUSAND THREE
AND AS A RESULT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF AREAS OF SILLY WILL
WE NEED TO REACTIVATE
IMPROPERLY MAINTAINING ORDER
CONDUCTED INITIAL TRAINING AT
THIS VENUE. THE OUR VISION FOR
THIS- TRAINING COMPLEX IS GOING
TO BE FOR THE ENTIRE DEPARTMENT
THIS IS NOT JUST AN EXTENSION
FOR THE ACADEMY BUT AROUND THE
FACILITY- AS A TRAINING COMPLEX
FIVE DAYS A WEEK AND OPEN IT UP
TO OTHER DEPARTMENT PROGRAMS
EVENTUALLY DOWN THE ROAD ALSO
FOR LOCAL- LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
UTILIZE. I'M ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE INSUFFICIENT MAYES
STAFF ON SITE RESULT IN SEVERAL
OPERATIONAL BENEFITS TO THE
DEPARTMENT- YOU KNOW STAFF ON
SITE IN THE EVENT OF
EMERGENCIES ABILITY FACILITATE
AND COORDINATE WITH OUR PLAN
OPERATIONS SUPERVISORS ME UNDER
DAILY WITH ISSUES AND OUR
MAINTENANCE RELATED WORK AND
THE FLEXIBILITY TO SIGN STAFF
TO MANAGE ANY OTHER SYSTEMS
THAT IS NEEDED. SO THE MAIN
PROGRAMS CONTINUE. WE DID LOOK
INTO YOU TO. I'M CURRENT ALL
STAFF I HAVE A COMPLEMENT OF
PLANT STAFF THAT RUN THE GOAL
ACADEMY BUT WITH THE WORKLOAD
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH THE GALL
A TREATING COMPLEX IT WOULD BE-
IT WOULD. ADD ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD X. THAT WOULD- XC WITH
THEIR ABILITIES ARE BEING ABLE
TO. OF CORRECT THINGS OF THE
STOCKTON FACILITY. AND WE ALSO
A CONTRACTING SO WE HAVE. THE
BERMAN FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS ON
THE TENNIS. AT MANY SHATTERED
HARMON A FINANCE- IN RESPONSE
TO IT WE DEFINITELY AGREE WITH
THE MAINTENANCE STAFF WE THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT YOU
CAN BORROW SET FROM OTHER
FACILITIES IN ADDITION TO THE
WORK LOAD WE NEED TO BE REALLY
SAPPY MIGLIOR WITH THE SYSTEMS
AT. LEAST THEY CAN BOND AND
EMERGENCY. ON THE DAY THE LIFE
TRAINING SERGEANTS BAD ISN'T
SCHEDULED TO COME ONLINE UNTIL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
THERE'D BE MORE THAN TWO YEARS
TO DEVELOP OUR SPORT. THE
ASSOCIATED STAFF. ALSO NOT
INCLUDED IN THE LINE AS WELL AS
THE QUESTION. ONE OF. THANK YOU
CENTER. THIS SEEMS
COUNTERINTUITIVE SO I THE NEED
IS AS OUR PRISON POPULATION
MINING AND A GOVERNOR WHO WANTS
EVEN CLOSE ONE. TOBY YOU'RE
RAMPING UP WITH STAFF AND I ANY
TEAMS ARE INTUITIVE SO MAYBE BY
CHANNEL THE SENATOR SKINNER I'D
ASK. ARE YOU THINKING WHY WHY
WHERE I DON'T SEE ANYTHING IN
HERE WHERE THE- THE NEED TO THE
DEMAND IS. JUSTIFIED EVEN GOING
INTO TRACK. ONE NINE I THINK
ONE THING THAT'S DIFFICULT. OR
YOU IS A COMMITTEE AND SORT OF
A AN INHERENT PROBLEM WITH THE
STATE BUDGET ITSELF IS THAT YOU
SEE PIECES OF IT THAT I WERE
TRYING TO JUSTIFY WE DO THINK
THAT THERE'S A NEED FOR THIS.
BUT YOU THERE ARE PIECES THE
BUDGET WE WERE LOSING STAFF AS
YOU KNOW. WE ARE OUT OF OUR
CONTRACTS OF OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES. ARE SORT OF RAMPING
DOWN ARE IN STATE CONTRACTS.
AND WE ARE LOSING STAFF
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE PROPOSAL
THIS IS KIND OF. ONE PIECE OF.
A BIG SPECTRUM BUT THERE ARE.
AREAS OF THE DEPARTMENT WHERE
OUR POSITION. POSITIONS ARE
GOING DOWN. STAY TUNED. IF THEY
GET IN USES OVER OVERTIME SO
WELCOME TO OUR FIRST FIVE OF A
OF THIS A YEAR YOU DID A GREAT
JOB SHALL CHANNELING SENATOR
SKINNER THERE TO WELCOME. ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS. BUT ONE OF THE
DRESSES ON THE SUIT. NO I THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND I THINK THAT
WAS THE LAST. OKAY WORDS THAT.
LET.